First, let's continue the girl power
with these two best friends.
Victoria and Katie saw the devastation
of the Texas storms firsthand
and they joined forces to deliver food to those in need.
They got in their cars and delivered meals
to the front doors of people who needed it most.
And Victoria and Katie joined us now.
I have so many questions, Victoria and Katie!
Hi!
(applause)
Oh, I'm so happy to meet best friends who do good things.
Thank you!
Victoria, what gave you the idea to do this?
What did you see?
What inspired, what got you jump-started?
Well I was staying home with my family,
with my fireplace, my power and my water.
I was fortunate of not to lose the power or the water.
So I'm eating and I was thinking, you know,
I need to help out because there's so many people
that do not have water, that do not have power.
So I call my best friend, Katie,
and I told her my plan and she got on board with me.
And that's when we started getting everything
together to do what we did.
And Katie, what did you do when your best friend calls you
and says, let's do something meaningful?
What do you spring into action with?
We automatically starting to call
a bunch of different food places
and to see who was open, who wasn't.
We finally found one, ordered a bunch of food.
Then we went and posted all over Facebook,
got a bunch of comments and responses
and then ended up calling a bunch of friends,
breaking up into three groups
and went and delivered it to everyone.
And Victoria, I know this is personal for you
because maybe you recognize what needs to be done
because of your story.
Will you quickly tell me about that?
Yes ma'am.
So I was in foster care most of my life through group homes
and I've also been homeless before.
I've hungry before with no help.
So I knew how they felt, cold and hungry.
So I just wanted to do something that I could for anybody.
And that's when I got the idea of, let me just
spend my money and get somebody something to eat
because this storm is tearing everybody
down at this point.
Victoria, I love you so much.
And I know that you guys are paying
for all of this with your own money
and you just are real life angels coming to the rescue.
Thank you.
And I'm wondering
if I can tag team and become your third angel,
because I wanna donate $5,000 to help you
just continue your mission.
(applause)
Oh my god.
You know what, let's just make it 10,000.
Victoria and Katie, you have got to keep showing us
how things are done.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for doing everything you're doing.
And we're gonna check back in
with you and see what you're doing
with the money and like keep teaching us.
And thank you 'cause that is the power of good friends.
(upbeat music)